next we're in the Netherlands where a
man known only as Bubble Boy is pushing
the limits of protective packaging in
this incredible stunt no Bubble Boy
don't do it this video has the Internet
bubbling with discussion over its
authenticity
give me those bubbles I want to bump
them but is bubble wrap really a good
alternative to the stairs Bubble Boy
kind of has the right idea here after
all we landed the Grover on Mars using
airbags bubble wrap is just a series of
small airbags the reason you get heart
when you jump off a building is that you
slow down suddenly
so what bubble wrap does is actually
increases the time it goes from very
fast to nothing and the way it does that
is that it absorbs energy it pops it
deforms so far so good but does he have
enough bubble wrap for safe landing nASA
has done tests on how many GS a human
being can experience and still survive
and what they found is that a human
could survive up to 45 G's without being
killed Bubble Boy has about four inches
or 10 centimeters of bubble wrap around
him and even if all of them compressed
perfectly and evenly he would still
experience about a hundred G's falling
from that height as a result Bubble Boy
should be dead I don't want to burst
anyone's bubble but this clip is
obviously fake remember use your bubble
wrap wrap popping and do not try this at
home
I'm bubble boy's arch-nemesis burst man